[Musik]
es ist eine sehr amerikanische art zu
demonstrieren
ein autokorso mit hunderten
pick-up-trucks die wahlniederlage ihres
präsidenten wollen diese trump anhängern
einfach nicht wahrhaben
am ende gibt es eine neuauszählung und
trank gewinnt alles wird gut
job ist unser präsident die beiden
familie ist kriminell
auf keinen fall werde ich ihn als
präsidenten akzeptieren seit tagen
machen die hardcore fans des präsidenten
mobil
das ziel der kolonne das parlament in
phoenix unter den demonstranten viele
schwer bewaffnet sie sind wütend können
einfach nicht glauben dass ihr
traditionell republikanischer staat
arizona an die demokraten geht
ich glaube das ist alles eine lüge
die großen nachrichtensender werden alle
von china oder russland kontrolliert
solange donald trump kämpft und solange
er das tut werden wir für sie da sein
warum sind die menschen hier so
aufgebracht welche ängste haben sie das
wollen wir im ländlichen arizona
herausfinden wo besonders viele trump
gewählt haben wir sind noch keine stunde
raus aus phoenix da fällt uns am
straßenrand ein munitions verkäufer auf
er selbst will vor der kamera nicht mit
uns sprechen wohl aber seine kunden
stolz präsentieren die ihren frischen
kauf munition für revolver und
maschinenpistole ein präsident biden
bedeutet für sie auch angst vor
steigenden munitions preisen oder dass
man ihnen gleich die waffen weg nimmt
unter obama sind die preise deutlich
hoch gewann unter trampe alles stabil
wenn jetzt beiden kommt geht es wieder
hoch
meiner meinung nach hat jeder das recht
auf selbstverteidigung
wenn du von anderen angegriffen wirst
musst du dich selbst verteidigen wir
fahren weiter raus aufs land hier ist
arizona besonders dünn besiedelt die
zeit scheint stehen geblieben zu sein
unser ziel die republikaner hochburg
prescott 90 prozent der menschen hier
sind weiß zwei von drei bällen schon vor
wenigen wochen hat der präsident hier
noch wahlkampf gemacht die menschen in
prescott sind tief gläubig auf die
44.000 einwohner kommen fast 50 kirchen
und wie überall in amerika ist kirche
hier auch event inklusive mittagessen
und showacts
[Musik]
der pastor erzählt uns für viele in der
gemeinde sein präsident biden eine
horror vorstellung der progressive
flügel der amerikanischen regierung will
uns viele konservative regeln wegnehmen
zum beispiel beim thema ehe für an- oder
abtreibung doch auch mit präsident trump
haben viele in der gemeinde hier ihre
probleme der konnte zwar inhaltlich
punkten zum beispiel mit der
konservativen besetzung des obersten
gerichtshofs seinen ständigen pöbeleien
dagegen halten viele für unchristlich
viel von der ernüchterung unter
konservativen vor allem unter
evangelikalen christen mit präsident
trump ist dass er sich nicht christlich
verhängt man sieht nicht viel demut
seine worte reflektiere nicht die werte
die uns wichtig sind ein paar straßen
weiter im heimatmuseum setzt sich stolz
auf die wildwest vergangenheit ihrer
stadt ende des neunzehnten jahrhunderts
verbrachten revolverhelden aller wyatt
earp und doc holliday zeit in prescott
christa ist rentnerin und arbeitet als
freiwillige im laden sie ist überzeugte
trump anhängerin den demokraten wirft
sie wahlbetrug vor
wir haben viele beispiele von betrug
gesehen das ist einfach nicht der
amerikanische weg das macht man nicht
mit freunden die demokraten gewählt
haben klammert christa das thema politik
inzwischen aus so schnell gebe es streit
wie beide seiten wieder zusammenwachsen
können
ich weiß es nicht ich weiß es wirklich
nicht
wir werden nicht randalieren das haben
wir konservative nicht in uns aber wie
unser land heilen kann
ich weiß es nicht
das palace ist in prescott eine echte
institution 1877 gegründet ist es die
älteste bar arizona becker ist in dem
heutigen restaurant managerin und
kellnerin in einem obwohl sie
konservativ ist sie trump kritisch er
sollte ein vorbild für alle sein
stattdessen haben wir ein land voller
erwachsene die sich wie eine horde
kinder benehmen die auf twitter gehen
und sich wie idioten verhalten niemand
verhält sich heute noch wie ein
erwachsener das problem sieht sie im
zwei parteien system der usa für
konservative die donald trump ablehnen
sagt sie uns gäbe es keine wirkliche
alternative
die leute sind hin und hergerissen
aber weil man nur zwei parteien zur
auswahl hat was macht man dem gibt man
seine stimme
die pöbeleien schramms wird hier kaum
jemand vermissen
sie sehnen sich nach einem konservativen
amerika der vermeintlich guten alten
zeit